basically here he's one move away from a
draw
that happened would be an enormous
achievement for
for him uh and he carelessly
decides to to to take her last pawn
and indeed what could be more natural
right
she has a rook and a knight and a king
against the rook and three pawns and
experienced chess players they will know
that against good defense
you cannot win with a rook and a knight
against
just a rook even if he loses
all his pawns he should be able to make
a draw
after he's grabbed that last pawn
however
he's been careless uh he's overlooked
the fact that
these pawns they're all in the way
and they're taking away squares from
from his rook and
simply by attacking uh the rook
with the with the king as she does
uh not once but but twice
she attacks the the rook the rook um
the rook has to move one square away and
then she attacks it with
with uh with the king again and at this
point
the rook has so many squares
it has practically a full board to
choose from
but wherever the rope goes it's either
going to be forked
by the knight or captured by the king
or the rook or or the knight then he
with a smile she realizes or that his
rooks is trapped
and then for some reason he doesn't
realize it as well
he moves the rook away and uh he gets
forked and he
and he loses uh really pretty uh